[Music]
foreign
s that come to the market over the past
number of years and for the most part
they've been relatively good we love the
flexible displays but they have been a
little bit delicate and not necessarily
a daily driver for a lot of us out there
who are more into physical activities
and want to have more creativity with
our phones but oppo's trying to change
that with the Oppo Find and to flip a
very first of its kind with some unique
technology very good cameras and a
vertical 3.2 inch OLED display on the
front of it which is going to change the
game when it comes to flip phones anyway
we're going to take it through a spaces
here we're going to walk and talk about
what it's like to use as a creative tool
not necessarily for you know daily stuff
would we use for emails and messages and
all that stuff but how we can create
with this device and run it through his
paces
let's do it
now when we talk about flip phones for
the most part A lot of these companies
try to market flip phones to the female
audience and I don't know why I mean
when I was growing up the star attack
and the razor were badass phones
but I'm liking what oppo's doing with
the find and two flip is they're also
targeting this to the male audience
especially with this astral black color
it's beautiful it's stealth it matches
the Hasselblad x2d which I have in my
backpack right here and I absolutely
love it now for the females out there we
also have the moonlit purple and some
guys will like that as well they want a
little pop of color in their life but
for me
gotta go black baby because once they
say once you go black
one of the things I love about this
design is this
zero Gap
no gap between the two displays when
they're closed together on other flip
phones we've seen to the market there's
a bit of a gap Oppo has refined this
with a flexion hinge now when you look
inside the phone you're going to notice
a teardrop shape so displays aren't
necessarily folded together like a piece
of paper there's a teardrop and then
they come together but when you look at
it from the outside due to the great
engineering from oppo's Team it just
looks like two displays melted together
as one but when then when you open it up
got about a 6.8 inch display on this
very relative to what we're using on
smartphones nowadays and it is fantastic
and I see a lot more smartphone
manufacturers using this type of
Technology and Engineering in their flip
phones going forward because this is
absolutely fantastic when you run your
finger over it you barely feel a crease
again a testament to the engineering
from Mobile's team for creating almost
an invisible crease unlike what we're
seeing from other foldable phones on the
market and this is going to improve over
time for sure I think over the next
couple years we're going to get to a
point where there's zero crease and Oppo
is definitely leading the way in that
charge because this looks fantastic to
use on a daily basis I don't see the
crease I barely feel it it works great
next let's talk about one of the big
design changes on this phone which I
absolutely love and that is that 3.2
inch OLED display on the front as you
notice it is
vertical
not horizontal because we live in a
Vertical World We Stand Up all of our
Instagram reels and tick tocks are shot
in torture motor vertical mode we live
in a Vertical World opal realizes that
hence why they got rid of the horizontal
display on the outside of it and made it
vertical this makes it a lot easier if
you want to do selfies want to record
video if you're in a group photo per se
you want to take a group shot Gerald
come in here come in here we're gonna
take a photo together cool things you
can take a group shot just by raising
your hand to the screen check this out
all right thank you very much
another thing you can do is actually
make it your own tripod that's right not
a tall tripod but you can put it onto a
table and you've got a nice shell like
this on an angle once again just hold on
my hand like this
three two one
there we go
just think of the content you could
create with this phone with you and your
loved one nice glass of you know Chianti
Bellissima
So speaking of the outside display you
could have up to five widgets currently
right now as of the time I'm recording
this now the one I primarily use is the
camera widget because you can do
portrait video and photography now I
hear there's gonna be a lot more widgets
coming to Market like something from
Spotify that we saw in the keynote I'm
looking forward to trying that out in
the meantime there's a lot of
information that can be put on this 3.2
inch OLED display on the front facing
especially for the widget side of things
now anyway Zacky let's go inside
let's shoot some awesome Turkish coffee
content with video and photo
let's go inside
have you had Turkish coffee before Zaki
come on let's do it
[Music]
so what I'm doing now is using camcorder
mode on this so I've got it flip like an
L shape so that way you actually have a
nice perspective when you're shooting
better for stabilization and you can
really move in on this and the cameras
on this for video are actually pretty
good so you can get some really good
video quality we're going to show you
what that looks like as well
[Music]
oh
now one of the things I appreciate about
this camera system is the hassle black
color Science Now opal always partnering
with Hasselblad once again we've seen
this in other phones from Oppo and it is
in this device we of course certainly
got a 50 megapixel for your main camera
then you have a eight megapixel for your
Ultra wide and then you've got a 32
megapixel for your selfie camera now of
course you can use the main cameras for
your selfie with a flip conversion we've
already shown how to do that of previous
times in this video but it's the color
science the natural skin tones the way
that this pomegranate just pops on
screen the coffee the colors here in in
Arab Street and kampung Glam it's
gorgeous and that is a testament to what
hasselbeck's been working on in their in
their camera systems especially the
hasselbot X series of cameras the x1d
x1d2 and x2d and you're seeing that
coming here with the opal collaboration
with Hasselblad as well
one of the attributes I like about this
phone though is it's sort of taking from
hasselblad's DNA from the v-series
cameras that waist level viewfinder
which you're gonna get some very
interesting angles and this is something
when you look at images from the past
years from the early 30s 40s and 50s a
lot of images where you saw people were
sort of from this angle that's the
reason for it so what you can do with
plan N2 flip is actually just flip it
like this you have the viewfinder here
at the bottom and then now I can
actually capture images like this so
it's a different perspective it's Unique
it's fun and as I walk through these you
can see all the colors you can see the
alloy but you're getting a different
perspective altogether which makes it
very unique and add something
interesting to the image so when people
look at your image it's not just that
standard like how I'm taking your shot
but it's more like it's a different
perspective in the world and it makes it
really enjoyable to use
now one of the things I like about this
one is the Mary silicone xnpu processor
it is a
it's like a neural process of it's
inside of the Opel final two flip and I
think this is where AI is coming into
play so it's really going to help with
lower light situations in terms of
reducing the noise keeping the color
vibrancy but at the same time keeping
the sharpness there so your images are
going to look better in lower light than
other phones as opposed claiming now
we're going to show you some sample
images from this beautiful Lantern shop
here to give you an idea of how this
holds up but it looks fantastic but
these lanterns are absolutely gorgeous
foreign
[Music]
now it's time to go into x-pan mode what
is x-pan mode well Hasselblad back in
the day made a panoramic 35 millimeter
film camera they actually made two
versions of this the x-pen one and the
x-pan 2. now those cameras nowadays are
no longer in production and if you were
to buy Mint Condition one they could be
upwards to 10 to 12 000 US dollars so to
save yourself some money Oppo with a
collaboration with Hasselblad has
actually included the x-band mode in the
fine N2 flip and so you can also shoot
this in color and in black and white and
it gives you a very different
perspective so it is a panoramic image
you can shoot horizontal or vertical and
it's basically a 65 by 24 aspect ratio
so uh taking images of these lanterns
right here you're actually going to get
this entire
shot like this at the same time I can go
black and white get a very cool dynamic
as well I'm going to also show you some
other images I've taken with the expand
mode which is arguably one of my
favorite features of the find N2 flip
when it comes to the cameras is that
mode
[Music]
now one of the attributes that I like
about this phone is actually the
packaging how it's presented to you it
comes in a very luxurious box something
different from other Oppo phones that
we've had and you know that this is
special because when you open it up it
tilts forward to you
this is a premium phone from opal even
though it's priced really good in the
foldable Market this is premium comes
with a fast charging brick assignment
which we always appreciate our charging
bricks as well as cases for this so to
protect this as well because this is an
investment we want to keep our flip
phones looking as beautiful as possible
without any scratches even though we've
got some really durable glass and
construction behind it it's always good
to have a case on this also pretty much
all day battery life around 40 4 300
milliamp battery inside of this now when
you're using both displays of course
you're going to see a little bit of
battery drainage but this is the largest
battery on any foldable phone that we're
seeing in this form factor to date so
that's another step up for over in that
regard 4 300 milliamp battery if you
don't use the outside display all the
time you're going to get all-day usage
no problem at all anyway
that's it for the specs that's it for
the packaging let's go and try something
awesome with video
I've always had this idea exactly
because with this we can record video
and we're using the main cameras on the
flip as you see the two camera cameras
here
and
if you notice it
here's video right here here's Zachy
myself we could walk and we could talk
the microphones are there what if we did
an action team Zach because the camera
here when you have to flip down it
shoots in 1080 the stabilization is
reduced now the reason I did find this
out from the Oppo developers the reason
it's only in 1080 is because they're
worried about the heat coming from 4K
that could affect the screen especially
since the screens are together and also
they reduce the stabilization but that
doesn't mean it's not usable that means
you become more creative with it we want
to pretend something is chasing me and
that I gotta get away all right here we
go
what's going on let's run come on come
on look out ah look at it all right
folks future Zaki here pulling you out
of bubbies wild imagination let's stick
it a step further and show you how to
create a cool video concept with the N2
flip first we need to establish the
story and the scene backpack yes you're
gonna look like you're carrying
something like really expensive away
from basically some bugs okay we're
gonna end up with a jump shot and then
end this other
gotcha okay ready ready okay let's do it
step two always plan your shots as if
you're gonna be editing it we're gonna
actually one like to call a camcorder
mode to film this segment of the scene
from the 90s exactly awesome and we're
gonna shoot it in 4k because we can
hinge it and if I ever need an angle I
can see it from half the screen so it's
not affecting me at all I can still get
a nice view all right in three two one
action
and what
all right so we got this bucket here
kind of use the clamshell mode and then
tilt it up so that when Bobby jumps over
the bucket it looks like he's giving it
a nice nice look to it
that's method acting right there shot
yeah and you're like linear against
something like nearby okay
all right and of course the final step
is to put it all together and enjoy the
process check this out Bobby Anna Jones
coming soon to theaters probably not
I'm showing this
this is my last message
whoever it is who finds this
clip is yours
take him
here's a wise Knight
[Music]
very second short film with that right
exactly good job man that's how we do it
exactly so flood ways to use the N2 flip
anyway
this is a point device man it really is
you know we can go respects we could
talk about all the specifications of the
chipsets but it's about what you could
create with a device like this which
makes it fun and it's pretty much got
all day battery life as well it's got
the largest battery related brick phone
on the market so on top of that got good
video quality hassle black colors great
photography fun video 4K 60s also gives
a little bit of slow motion of me
jumping over
anyway
if you guys like this video subscribe to
the channel and hit that like button
more great content on the way
now it's time to take more photos
foreign